[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
choisir cette semaine votre magazine
dédié aux idées sorties problème pour un
enregistrement à frans signature à
elancourt le sommaire de ce jeudi 4
avril après un repos hivernal bien
mérité le parc où 117 maquette s'apprête
à démarrer une nouvelle saison nous
avons délocalisé nos caméras pour une
émission spéciale au centre du parc
avant sa réouverture ce samedi 6 avril
du 5 au 22 avril la commanderie donne
carte blanche à un chorégraphe
une opération qui entre dans la mission
de danse de la structure nous serons
autour du programme une ouverture sur le
tombeau de toutankhamon après son tour
du monde l'exposition événement c'est un
tout dernier arrêt à la grande halle de
la villette découverte que toutankhamon
le trésor des pharaons deux ans avant
l'ouverture du parc en 1991 c'est une
quarantaine d'ateliers qui ont été
mobilisés pour la réalisation des
maquettes
depuis chaque année elles ont droit à
leur trêve hivernale reportage au sein
de l'atelier de france miniature dans
l'atelier de france miniature
le château de versailles va se faire
refaire une beauté chez toi on a bien
besoin là ici on a un joli centre
et puis là si on passe la main ça fait
des vagues chaque hiver et des maquettes
ont droit à un peu de nettoyage et pour
certaines comme la bâtisse du roi soleil
une restauration complète mine de rien
veille dans leur 28e année et elle
souffre comme nous des années qui
passent donc globalement oui c'est la
restauration la réfection et l'entretien
de façon à ce que elle dure le plus
longtemps possible les présente bien le
maquettiste retravaille les bâtiments de
la toiture aux petites sculptures dont
chacune a son propre moule importants
chantiers en cours la création de 250
orangé pour le parc du château
il faut aussi qu'on trouve des matériaux
qui soit durable dans le temps on a
essayé pas mal de choses notamment les
fleurs artificielles mais ça ça vieillit
pas très bien assez rapidement ça c'est
cuit au soleil et les meilleurs
résultats sont obtenus avec le gazon
artificiel qui est un de nos alliés sur
le parc plus loin les maquettes de passe
par l'atelier couleurs
le peintre décorateur reprend
minutieusement le toit de l'abbaye saint
antoine
je pose d'abord le vert ensuite je veux
poser le rouge en bande large et ensuite
le noir va s'appuyer sur le rouge
ce qu'il faut c'est que les quatre
bandes est à peu près la même épaisseur
et qu'elles soient bien dirigées les
maquettes sont rénovées mais doivent
conserver un aspect vieilli par le temps
comme leur modèle d'origine plus qu'un
travail de couleur c'est un travail de
matière pour cela il faut jouer avec
toutes sortes ingrédients magiques
conservés dans des bocaux
par exemple ça c'est de la poudre de
briques qu'on colle avec de la peinture
ou colleter avec la peinture et ça
permet d'avoir des bons effets sur les
toitures
si vous avez une poudre de mika
certaines toitures ont des brillances
comme ça donc on en met un petit peu au
col dans la peinture les 117 maquette du
parc sont entre de bonnes mains
le château de versailles peut de nouveau
à arborer ses dorures et à côté de lui
sa principale concurrente aussi retrouve
une nouvelle jeunesse trop lourde à
déplacer la dame de fer de 10 mètres à
son propre échafaudages et ne connaît
pas l'atelier reine des monuments de
france sont ces restaurateurs qui
viennent à elle c'est donc sous cette
tour eiffel que je retrouve fabrice la
loure le directeur du parc bonjour
bonjour alors là elle est fraîchement
rénové d'ailleurs ça modèle original
vient de fêter ses 130 ans ici elle est
plus jeune et elle a eu un droit un très
bon spécial quand elle est arrivée sur
la rive en 91
évidemment ça à un monument phare de
france miniature et là à l'arrivée dès
l'ouverture et le monument pèse trois
tonnes tout un peu compliqué de le faire
entrer sur les années et qu'on l'a
découpée en trois morceaux et puis elle
est arrivée par hélicoptère
donc c'est par hélicoptère qu'elle était
posé sur le centre du parc donc là on
l'a vu dans le reportage
elle est restée sur place pour sa
restauration qu'est ce qu'il est arrivé
exactement
alors il a fallu un petit lifting parce
que c'est vrai qu'avec le temps les
couleurs se défraîchir un petit peu la
pallice et du coup on l'a complètement
hors pair ou vraies couleurs de la tour
eiffel sur le brun tour eiffel qui est
pas soit sous la toiture manager vous
fait à peu près tous les dix ans et ça
c'est ça c'est ça tous les dix ans à peu
près il faut la reprendre parce que la
peinture c'est encore une fois se
défraîchir un petit peu avec le temps
avec les uv
parce que c'est évidemment le soleil
qu'il aa dégrade davantage encore que la
pluie ou là
donc si on reprend un peu l'histoire du
parc sa création on la doit à deux
hommes l'un passionné de maquettes le
petit train c'est à celui qui était
passionné de petites robes et cherche à
réaliser un parc d'attractions à parc
miniature et le seconde ligne pour des
études sur la couverture et post quitté
le bénin parc d'attractions c'était son
dossier de fin d'études et les deux ont
fusionné leurs idées c'est comme ça que
france miniature a vu le jour en 1991
donc là aujourd'hui on l'a dit c'est 117
monument sur un terrain de 5 hectares en
forme de l'hexagone en forme de france
combien vous avez de visite à peu près
par an alors ça fluctue évidemment d'une
saison sur l'autre force miniature est
en nette progression ces dernières
années on a accueilli l'année dernière
195 milles visiteurs et avec un objectif
de passer la barre des 200 militants
cette année car cet objectif ya des
nouveautés les choses qui sont mises en
place chaque année il ya des nouveautés
a dit un nouveau calendrier d'animations
tout au long de la saison avec des
chasses aux autres sur pâques des
découvertes autour des abeilles
halloween en fait donc tout à kawéni qui
conclut la saison france miniature
on a une grosse actualité également
cette année avec une nouveauté condor
est un accro branches le cirque d un
acte qui la permettent aux enfants de
passer d'atelier en atelier et de
franchir des obstacles en hauteur mais
parce que ça on l'a dit le parc c'est
pas qu'une balade ya aussi un espace
jeux même au sein de la balade vous
faites des choses assez ludique et
didactique ya également des activités
qui sont proposées
quiconque tue le circuit de visite n'ont
qu'à quatorze ateliers sur le circuit
physique donc permet à nos visiteurs sur
marseille de déplacer des containers par
exemple et de répondre à des petites
questions faire des lâchers d'eau sur un
barrage pour voir la production de
d'électricité et puis a également une
grotte où on perd mais qui permet aux
enfants de dessiner sur les murs des
peintures rupestres france miniature
c'est vrai aussi que vous accueillez qui
alors c'est principalement des familles
avec enfants mais c'est vraiment tout
public soit en promenade familiale
qu'est la rouverture c'est ce week end
tout est prêt alors tout est prêt pour
le 6 avril il ya encore évidemment des
ajustements on est quelques vous
quelques jours encore de l'ouverture
chaque saison ou jusqu'au dernier moment
pas ses derniers coups de pinceaux et
les maquettes sorto l'oseille moment où
on sera prêt pour une levée de rideau 6
avril donc il me reste plus qu'à vous
souhaiter une bonne saison 2010 9 merci
de nous avoir accueillis sur le parc de
la mairie
et si vous le retrouvez plus
d'informations sur france miniature pour
la billetterie etc
c'est sur le site internet
[Musique]
dans le cadre de sa mission dans ce la
commanderie donne carte blanche à david
rolland et sa compagnie éponyme sur le
thème de la construction et la
déconstruction il investit les lieux du
5 au 22 avril
au programme de la danse bien sûr mais
aussi l'exposition dont le vernissage
aura lieu le premier jour
particularité du chorégraphe des
spectacles participatifs où le
spectateur est invité à devenir acteur
ce spectacle a pu manif créé en 2011
prend la forme d'une déambulation
audioguidée un jeu de rôle grandeur
nature
vous pouvez en retrouver plusieurs tout
au long de sa carte blanche ce qui m'a
inspiré dans dans ce lieu c'est bon à la
fois bien sûr sans son histoire les
templiers
le fait que ça devienne une ferme puis
un lieu de résidence pour des
plasticiens et puis ce qui s'y fait
aujourd'hui grâce à ces quatre
départements missionnés sur la danse les
itinéraires poétique la science et les
officiels un peu plus loin mais toujours
en plein air direction livre de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines
pour la troisième année consécutive des
portes ouvertes sont organisées elles
ont lieu ce week-end des 6 et 7 avril et
ce qui est bien une grandeur nature
initiation au paddle et saut à
l'élastique à verser les activités sur
nombreuses
retrouvez le programme sur le site
internet de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
promouvoir le savoir-faire et les
créations artisanales c'est l'objectif
de l'association la révolution du fait
main ce samedi 6 d'avril ces deux
créatrices organisent leur deuxième
édition du printemps des créateurs
plus de 60 exposants la plupart des
yvelines seront présents au carré de la
marée place du marché notre dame à
versailles des grandes gueules du cinéma
aux yeux d'elsa c'est votre rubrique
dans les salles saint-quentinoise de
patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
dans vos salles de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cette semaine
vous retrouverez le festival play it
again c'est un festival qui a pour but
de mettre en valeur les films du
patrimoine qui ressorte chaque année
dans les salles de cinéma françaises
cette année
le grenier à sel de trappes le signer
cette année d'encours et nous as anciens
l'école au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
nous reprenons un certain nombre de
films qu'on a choisi dans un catalogue
alors évidemment on peut pas tous faire
prendre nous ici ce sera des grands
anciens fondamentaux comme la strada ou
modica mais aussi des films plus
précieux comme breaking away olivia une
infime vraiment à découvrir le vieil
homme et l'enfant ou alors le grand les
grandes gueules de robert enrico nous on
a décidé de mettre en avant ce film là
cette année les grandes gueules c'est le
deuxième long métrage de robert enrico
il commence toujours sa carrière tout le
monde connaît robert enrico pour le
vieux fusil évidemment pour eau pour des
films comme cela là c'est vraiment le
tout démarrage de sa carrière et dès le
démarrage de sa carrière il va réunir
lino ventura bourvil pour faire un film
de truands un film de travail un film
qui se passe au coeur des vosges un film
d'hommes comme on en faisait vraiment
beaucoup à cette époque là où il ya des
gueules qui se retrouvent et moi je vous
retrouve propose de venir retrouver ces
gueux là au cinéma les yeux d'elsa le 12
avril
et puis j'essaierai de vous en dire un
peu plus y aura même un petit bonus
le court métrage la rivière du hibou de
robert enrico je vous attends nombreux
le 12 avril et pendant toute la période
du festival play it again dans les
salles de saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
pour découvrir les arts martiaux et les
sports de combat plusieurs associations
inimitable propose une journée spéciale
dédiée à ces différentes disciplines
une deuxième édition qui répond au
succès de la précédente pour vous
exercer aux acquis que ce samedi 6 avril
au centre sportif pierre de coubertin ce
dimanche 7 avril à partir de 9h15 vous
pourrez vous dégourdir les jambes avec
la 25e édition de la guye en course 3
course pour les enfants et un 10 km au
départ du gymnase des droits de l'homme
500 participants sont attendus
vous le voyez derrière moi depuis le
pont du gard je vous amène au pays des
pyramides le 4 novembre 1922 britannique
découvrez la tombe de toutankhamon a
découverte exceptionnelle exposition
spéciale toutankhamon le trésor du
pharaon est à découvrir à la grande
halle de la villette
reportage de mein esquermoise de nos
confrères dia grand paris tenté de
percer un mystère de plus de 3000 ont
comme howard carter en 1922 pénétrer
dans le tombeau de toutankhamon et
découvrez les trésors qui l'accompagnait
pour sa monté aux cieux comme cette
statue du roi amon qui est là pour le
protéger
son cercueil et reconstituer tous les
ornements autour de son corps sont
présents sauf son masque emblématique
qui lui restera de vitam aeternam en
egypte l'ordre dans lequel les objets
sont en place et ça correspond en fait à
l'ordre de découverte de ces objets dans
la tombe et on avance jusqu'au plus
intimes
jusqu au plus près du corps du roi puis
on passe à la salle du trésor
et puis maintenant nous sommes sortis on
a découvert la tombe et on à la
conclusion de cette histoire
toutankhamon il est découvert il ya
plein d'aléas d'histoire et puis à la
fin
eh bien on à la statue et on avait voulu
l'oblitérer c'est celui qui est devenu
le plus célèbre de l'histoire égyptienne
c'est une chance unique de découvrir 150
objets prêtés par le musée du caire
avant la fin de sa construction comme
son lit et ses armes fétiche ou encore
ici sont marc et son bouclier une
multitude de statuettes à son effigie
est également présentée il y à des
objets qui ont réellement appartenu à
toutankhamon j'entends
ont réellement été utilisée quand il
était vivant et là ça nous donne des
informations alors bien sûr toujours sur
le devenir fait une erreur du roi mais
ça nous donne des informations sur voyez
des choses qui sont vraiment personnel
ce qu'on ne peut jamais faire avec un
roi
je viens on a des vêtements ils disent à
qui la portait donc ça nous ça nous
montre comment pouvait s'habiller
toutankhamon dans la vraie vie c'est
inimaginable un truc pareil
cette expo sarah va être l'exposition de
ce siècle cela faisait cinquante ans que
toutankhamon n'avait pas mis les pieds
en france avec treize mille billets
vendus en prévente le trésor du pharaon
devrait connaître un succès égal à
l'exposition du siècle au petit palais
en 1967 et c'est la fin de ce numéro le
set it was il rentre à la rédaction
bonne semaine sur tv 78
[Musique]
oh
tous